factor 25 x squared minus 30x plus 9 and
so we have a leading coefficient that's
not a 1 and it doesn't look like there
are any common factors both 25 and 30
are divisible by 5 but 9 is it divisible
by 5 so we could factor this by grouping
but if we look a little bit more
carefully here see something interesting
25 is a perfect square and so 25 x
squared is a perfect square it's the
square of 5 X and then 9 is also a
perfect square it's the square of 3 or
actually it could be the square of
negative 3 this could also be the square
of negative 5 X so maybe just maybe this
could be a perfect square so let's just
think about what happens when we take
the perfect square of a binomial
especially when the coefficient on the
x-term is not a 1 so if we have a X plus
B squared what will this look like when
we expand this into a trinomial well
this is the same thing as ax plus B
times ax plus B which is the same thing
as ax times ax ax times ax is a squared
x squared plus ax times B which is a B X
plus plus B times ax which is another
you could call it b ax or a b x plus b
times v so plus b squared so this is
equal to a squared x squared plus these
two are the same term plus 2 a B X plus
B squared so this is what happens when
you square it a binomial now this
pattern seems to work out pretty good
let me rewrite our problem right below
it we have 25 x squared minus 30x plus 9
so if this is a perfect square then that
means that the a squared part right over
here is 25 and then that means that the
B squared part and that means that the
let me do this in a different color the
B squared part is 9
that tells us that a that a could be a
could be plus or minus five and that B
could be and that B could be plus or
minus three now let's see if this gels
with this middle term if these four this
middle term to work out for this middle
term to work out I'm trying to look for
good colors to a B this part right over
here to a B needs to be equal to
negative 30 or another way let me write
it over here to a B needs to be equal to
negative 30 or if we divide both sides
by 2 a B needs to be equal to negative a
B needs to be equal to negative 15 so
that tells us since their product is
negative 1 has to be positive and one
has to be negative now lucky for us the
product of 5 & 3 is 15 so if we make one
of them positive and one of them
negative will get up to negative 15 so
it looks like things are going to work
out so we could select we could select a
is equal to positive 5 and B is equal to
negative 3 those will work out those
would work out to a B being equal to
negative 15 or we could make a is equal
to negative 5 and B is equal to positive
3 so either of these will work so if we
factor this out this could be either a
is negative this first one it could
either be a is 5 B is negative 3 so this
could eat either be 5 X minus 3 squared
a is 5 B is negative 3 a is 5 B is
negative 3 it could be that or you could
have we could switch the signs on the
two terms or a could be negative 5 and B
could be positive 3 or it could be
negative 5 X plus 3 plus 3 squared so
either of these are possible ways to
factor this term out here and you're to
wait how does this work out how can both
of these multiply to the same thing well
this term remember this negative 5x plus
3 we could factor out a negative 1 so
this right here is the same thing as
negative 1 times 5x minus 3 the whole
thing square
and that's the same thing as negative 1
squared times 5x minus 3 squared and
negative 1 squared is clearly equal to 1
so that's why this and this are the same
thing this this comes out to the same
thing as 5x minus 3 squared which is the
same thing as that over there so either
of these either of these are possible
answers